hello beautiful people how are you happy
friday today we started a little early
because we want to keep you on your toes
and i'm i'm really excited to see what
mark does with this especially my 14
year old son i told him we're going to
be designing
redesigning the razer logo you got
really excited he's like yeah for real
i'm like no not for real this is
unofficial but maybe somebody from
razer's paying attention
uh marketing director we'd love to work
with you
so let's get into it today we're going
to be talking about
the logos that you love to hate
and we're going to be doing the redesign
with none other than mart
beeman is that how you say your last
name how do you say your last name
oh you have to pronounce yes yeah once i
like that
but it was a good try it was a good try
and if you
want to get in contact with mart here's
how you get in touch with him on
instagram he's mart
bumance and he's from the netherlands
and apparently they're dealing with
the pandemic pretty well i think all
right
you guys are doing pretty good i'm glad
to hear that somebody's doing this right
and
you can check out his work at
marksbubonds.com
and see the wonderful illustration work
which we don't ever talk about in the
show but he's a really good illustrator
as well
okay so let's look at the logos you know
what
jonah this is screwing me up i don't
know what we're looking at i don't get
the preview screen anymore
anyways we're going to be tackling the
rather famous or infamous logo the
the three snakes coiled together for
razor and we want to see what he's going
to do with it
but i always have to ask our design
professionals
why why design something for razer
take it over okay so um
first of all i don't hate that logo um
just i think there's a couple of things
that can be improved yeah for example
when you're looking at my screen that
i'm not sure if i'm sharing it at the
moment but um
i kind of like typography it's just that
uh when you scale it down
the snakes become really hard to
recognize and also because the outline
is
quite thin i think that could be a
better connection between the symbol and
topography so
i mean for the people that don't know
the razer it's it's a gaming uh
industry brand they design mouse mice
keyboards gaming maps stuff like that
and i actually like
most of their branding i think the the
way they
do product photography um the way they
use color
the way their website design is all
pretty neat i just think there could be
some small tweaks on the logo that could
improve and elevate it a bit more so
that's why i chose that logo
so this guy a little bit of background
be behind the brand
um why they chose the name razer it was
really weird stories and one of the
co-founders had the accident with the
razor
and then they wanted to launch this
company and they accidentally
misspelled the world when they fought
for the trademarks
so basically since then they were using
the wrong
wrong spelling of razer but they just
stuck with it
and the symbol um i got this from one
one of the interviews they gave a while
ago
i think a couple of years ago uh when
they first started
is that uh the the logo looks like the
mice the
one of the first mice looks like that it
had a logitech miles for lunch
so that's why they use snake snakes that
first
product was uh recall the razor boom
slang and that's where
the green color comes from because the
boom slang is a green
snake from africa i think so that's like
the
small story behind that logo um this was
the logo
the first one they used oh yeah and
until like 2008 or something like that
i'm not quite sure
and then they modified the a little bit
they updated typography
i think that's where they kind of like
missed the chance to do it all at once
but yeah now maybe it's it's maybe
they're like setting themselves up to at
least into another chain and you know
but i think the the
the symbol can still be improved i quite
like the topography
but i also changed topography a little
bit in the end
so this will like what i like about the
logo the three added snake i think
that's something that's
quite recognizable the triangle shape is
also quite dynamic
and because of the story about the razer
with the way to come came up with the
name
i think it's maybe even as like a small
connection with like the throwing stars
or the the like the
the weapons kind of has like a small
like razor
connection and i kind of also like the
the tilted angle on the logo
as you can see here it's not like
perfectly aligned to the vertical uh
angle but it's slightly tilted and i
think it
adds a nice dynamic to the logo and i
also like the typography but i'm still
going to change it a little bit
so what i think can be improved is the
snakes are way too complex except
for example in the middle it looks
really
messy especially when it's scaling down
so in my
version i'm trying to keep the the tip
of the snake but i'm
going to clean this middle part up a bit
and i'm also removing the outlines
because i think it's better to have like
one solid color instead of having the
black and green
so that you can also use it on a white
background black background green
background
so it's becomes a bit more versatile
so these are some of the sketches i made
and i'm now going to show a video of how
i made the sketches and
it will show like how i got to my final
logo design
i'm reading a comment here it's like
people love to see your design process
mart
yeah that's actually um like for example
um i watched the episodes of hadil and
um
marcus or mark and they focus really on
like the brand strategy and the brand
identity and stuff like that
because i but i read like a lot of
comments from most
episodes that i was a part of and people
always commented on like my sketching
process so that's why i chose to
focus mainly on that so the video for
sketching is actually a bit longer than
normal
and my idea was to basically store the
video and if people have questions how i
do something
i can dive into photoshop and maybe even
do it live so that was my idea for like
this episode
i will just start the video and if you
have questions or whatever just let me
know and i will
i can pause it okay yeah
so this is what i always do if i have
like a logo which i have to redesign and
just
make some quick notes of what i want to
change so i don't forget anything or
maybe if things will pop into my mind
later i'll just add them
so here i'm just redrawing the razer's
logo for memory and the reason i did
this because
i wanted to find out what i would be
able to remember like
just taking one glass of the logo and
then redrawing it
and the left one is the one i redraw
from memory
and the right one is the one i redraw
after seeing it again
so you immediately notice that the
middle part is so complex i wasn't even
able to remember
what it looked like so in my sketches
that was one of the first things that i
ditched
and just decided to make the middle part
more
i guess more simple and keep the
identity of the the the snakes on the
outer part
so this is just me trying a ton of
variations how the snakes might be able
to look
what the tail of the snake might look
like if they're going to be
twirled into each other or cut off or
just trying out variations what it might
look like
i like that part of your process is to
take a look at the logo and then just
turn it off and then redraw it
so that's your recall the recall ability
because complex logos
they're very hard to remember and i
think most designers who have seen this
before
know what i'm talking about where they
ask people to draw their favorite logos
and they're pretty horrible
representations mostly because they're
our memory is not as good as we think it
is yeah
so i wanted to create something that was
a bit easy to remember and also a bit
easy for people to
be able to draw themselves not so much
because people really need to draw the
logo but it's
when you're able to draw something
yourself even if you're not a designer
or whatever
it means that you have like a good
understanding of what the logo looks
like
so i think it's just a good test for uh
keeping it simple yeah
that's also why these sketches like the
first sketches that i'm making are just
straight lines and
very simple just i just want to get an
idea of the balance between the
thickness of the lines the the spacing
between the
the curls of the snake just trying out
what works and what doesn't work
and eventually i'm just going to pick
someone or
something that's just looks balanced on
the eye you know
are you drawing with a triangle template
underneath this that i cannot see
because how are you getting this all
lined up like that
no i'm just drawing it freehand but i
know what the angles on the triangle are
so i'm
drawing the first step uh just
by drawing it and then rotating it the
same degrees every single time
so i think it's like 120 degrees to get
like the perfect
triangle mm-hmm
so this like one third of the the logo
and then i'm
rotating it the same steps every time
damn you make it look so easy dude i i
can't say i
i'm not gonna hide it i can't i can't
draw like this this is like i
i think i can draw but man the way you
do this
it just seems like so fluid and so easy
for you
oh there's something interesting going
on here
yeah a lot of people are commenting like
insane sketching process they would love
to see you
stream uh on a regular basis
yeah i've actually thought about doing a
bit more of
youtube videos or maybe streaming or
whatever myself because
people always just see the finished
product and they never really see what
process goes into it so i think that
might be interesting to
do it a bit more maybe for myself as
well to show people like what
actual the work is that goes into
designing on norway you know
yeah i love that idea except for the
fact that uh you should just give us all
your videos we'll post them here
with me man you guys have a lot more
engagement a lot more followers so
that's good
that's a fair deal to me we'll take
whatever you got man
so did you uh are you drawing a snake
from memory
like you know this the size of the the
head of the snake is a certain way
or just look at a bunch of photos
i didn't hear your answer i'm sorry this
is this just from memory
memory okay i think we all have a sense
of like yeah
we know what a snake looks like yeah but
then when you go to draw it sometimes
like something is off you know like the
shape of the head or the tongue or
something like that
i mean it's strong and this is also sped
up a little you know so
um i think the total process of
sketching which i took for this for this
stream was about seven or eight hours
and it's
sped up into 15 or 20 minutes now so
that goes there's more time that goes
into it than what you see right now it's
not like
this is my usual speed you know yeah i
mean if you drew
at this speed game over everybody just
quit design right now
yeah so when you're sketching like this
do you
take a break do you go and watch
something else what do you what's it
like in between the first moment that
you
make your first stroke and then when
you're done
i think i have a total of like 15
recordings from obs
where i recorded my scheme where i was
sketching so i think most
um how do you say it sessions of
sketching
yes we're around one hour or maybe 40
minutes i see
and i i really like to work on like
three or four projects at the same time
so when i'm out of ideas for one project
i just work on another one
and then all of a sudden new ideas come
into my head for the projects i was
working on before
it's just letting go of a project for
some time
can really help to you know get some
fresh ideas and
maybe just browse the internet a bit
watch some netflix or watch a movie or
go outside
it really helps me to clear my head and
get some fresh ideas for the new
sketches
okay there's a question that's coming in
here and the uh xanthe wants to know
what what platform hardware software
you're using
obviously you're using photoshop what
are you running this on
um well this is a gaming brand and i'm
working on windows because i like to
play games every now and then so
windows and i'm using a wacom tablet to
do my sketches
what's the brand of the tablet uh the
computer the laptop
uh it's it's self-built so it's oh okay
uh it's not a laptop then it's a it's a
pc
yes okay i see so you can tell
he marked into this because he's
building his own pc you guys well
actually a friend of mine built it but
okay yeah like i i gave him i gave him a
budget
and i told him this is what i want to be
able to do with it and then he
selected the parts and the case and
stuff like that and he came to my home
to build it
but this computer is already like six
seven years old so i'm actually planning
on buying a new one soon
when the crisis is over how much did you
originally spend
what was the budget for this pc build uh
i think
including the monitor and um keyboard
and mice
i think like 1800 euros well that's not
too bad i thought you're gonna
drop a crazy number on us because gaming
gaming machines can be expensive because
of the video board
yeah but when you're used to apple then
everything is cheap
very careful tread lightly my friend no
i mean
it was it was it was doable and i'm
using it both for
my hobbies and also for my work so it
was worth the money
yes for sure anthony sanchez pc master
race a big smiley face there okay
whatever
whatevs oh what i really like about when
you build your own pc is when you need
an upgrade you can
you don't need to like completely buy a
new pc but you can also
um invest on some new parts you know
stuff like that
yeah now you're just being cruel i'm
sorry i'm sorry
okay what's your favorite gaming pc like
uh
hardware company like a manufacturer
it's hard to say because it depends on
what you need to buy for example if you
want uh
video cards and it's going to be
different than what you the brender that
you're using for your mice or whatever
so
i think most gaming pcs have like six or
seven brands
inside the case but like off the shelf
is there one brand in particular
you prefer you what are the big gaming
brands i like razer
i like the i like racer for example they
make laptops do
i think they do i'm not quite sure i
think they do
okay we should find out i know there's
gamers in here what are the big gaming
brands because we should just mention it
in case they're watching
and then magically maybe pc will appear
i'm trying to help you here but you're
not helping me okay but i was trying to
just like
don't mention any names because i'm
doing the stream for race and i've got
if i'm going to mention
i just check now right now
maybe that'll make them a little bit
more aggressive and reach out yeah
maybe let's hope so who knows
sometimes they do have a laptop by the
way they have the razor blade
yeah i thought that they do have pcs
right
yeah yeah i think i started on the
website as well yeah
so this that's the part where i've
already selected the sketch which i
really like
and now i'm just cleaning it up and
making sure that everything is
balanced equally and also um
not just uh mathematically but also
optically you know
this part is looking pretty tricky right
here so you created some red and green
bands are they equidistant like the red
and green stripes or no
no the so the spacing between the white
strokes is
75 of the white strokes i think
i actually um i don't do it by
calculating every time i just i do it by
um
just looking at it and think seeing what
looks balanced
and then just finding a number that is
equal to what that
just drew from my mind you know yeah
so sometimes the space between the
stroke and
the next stroke will be one x and next
the next time it will be one and a half
that's not like a magic number for it
i often really like like these
discussions about the golden ratio and
stuff like that and
i'm not really a big fan of of that to
be honest because i think it's just
important to take a step back and just
look at your design and
see if it's balanced or not and then
based on your sketch then come up with a
number that
will work with your illustrator file
yeah
there's too much to be made about the
whole golden ratio thing and people
think that just because you use it your
your design is going to be magical and i
promise you if you're terrible designer
it's not going to do anything for you
i think it's more like a happy accident
when it works
than when you really put thought into it
so now i'm just also sketching some
typography to see
what kind of font i want to design that
works well with the symbol because
that's
the only complaint i had about the font
is that
i really like it when the logo has like
a
cool symbol but also a typography that
works well with the symbol not that's
you have a simple design and you just
add a font afterwards and it looks like
an afterthought so
yeah that's why i'm designing something
custom to make sure that it works well
with the symbol
no i don't know if you guys noticed he
did it really fast but he took the angle
from the
the three snakes and he repeating that
and that's really important
in design and just pulling parts of the
icon
into the word you will see it again here
mark
so here the the stroke is the red and
the gap the space is the green right
so the symbol and the topography are
reversed on the symbol the
strokes are the green part and on the
topography the strokes are the red parts
but even that you did that it's kind of
interesting because he's kind of
i mean you're you're saying like i'm
really not into this whole golden ratio
thing too too much
foster's being made of it but he is
intrinsically
intuitively working this way anyways
he's making sure the proportions are
related it's not arbitrary
all right we caught some heat here we're
at 466 people watching and from
just a couple hundred so people are
really enjoying this i'm gonna assume
so i'm just trying out some variations
of the so this was actually the the
topography that i went with
i'm just trying out some variations and
i didn't end up going with this because
i didn't really like the angles on the
art
mm-hmm i think that was a good choice
there good
to do that it looked a bit uh
gimmicky bit too much i agree just
prefer to get something that's
a bit more clean because the the symbol
itself is already quite busy you know
but
already quite intricate and detailed so
i also kind of like where you're
exploring a narrower typeface and
more extended so kind of i'm excited to
see what you land on
now somebody is saying here lee bach is
saying man his photoshop sketches are
more precise than
most illustrator logos hello
and i can't argue that
so this is what i always do at the end
when i've picked a sketch that i like
just trying out the different color
variations and i've actually picked
the green color of the razer logo that
was already being used
and i changed it just slightly because i
noticed that
the cream color they used wasn't really
visible on a white background so i
picked a green color that's
both visible on black and on white
someone told you to stop this is already
amazing
[Laughter]
thanks for tuning in that's it for our
live stream today we'll see you guys
next week
i appreciate it's just under here you
know what though what's really
interesting is that
sometimes we do something and
through objective eyes we're like well
this is so good and sometimes designers
get lost in the design process and they
actually make it
worse sometimes
so now i'm just stepping into
illustrator and i'm basically
repeating most of the steps that i did
in photoshop but this time i'm using the
grid of illustrator and using snap to
grid so that
everything is perfect i saw that you
scaled it up so it lined up onto that
grid right
so you're repeating the same process
again the stroke and the gap
i mean we've talked about this before
the reason i do this is because i
i just prefer to sketch in photoshop so
i do it basically i
basically do the same tips twice i mean
some people
might be able to do this in illustrator
right away but my personal preference
just starting in photoshop and
getting the sketch as clean as possible
there and then moving to illustrator
now can i assume that that line the
angle is 120 degrees because since it's
an equilateral triangle yeah yeah
and as you can see as well it's the
circles that i'm using
like with topography i wanted them to be
optically
nice straight line but when you're
actually putting it on the line then it
looks like it's a bit more down so i
used a small
i guess overshoot as well like with
topography to put it up just slightly a
bit more towards the top
now are your circles ellipses are they
perfect circles
uh they're perfect circles right
and i actually didn't made a mistake as
i had to redo this step
so you're capable of making mistakes
it's not what you're saying i was
thinking about editing it out but
i just you know
once in a while i think you should just
like have totally some random thing in
there so people are like oh
yeah you gotta screw that well actually
that's a look at this video but no one
noticed um i think at like
the third minute or whatever you could
see my foot order on the screen
i saw it i saw a screen you know like
what the heck is that
yeah that was my foot order but it was
so fast you couldn't see it
so you get your food delivered to your
place sometimes when i'm lazy when i'm
trying to finish a logo for the future
then sometimes i can do it
your reward will be you can eat when
you're done exactly
and i also like to support the local
businesses at the moment you know
because
tough times for the restaurant stuff
like that so maybe yeah all the food
every now and then it's not that bad
i don't know i think it's great we got
to support each other
and then if that restaurant needs a
website or a logo they need to call you
up exactly it's called the circle of
life guys
okay we're up to 564 it's growing can we
get to 600 before this thing is over i
don't know
let's see it's almost over so hurry up
tell your friends guys we need another
46 or 47 people
or 37 people to tune in all right
i've tried to design logos like this
before where it's one
symbol and it's rotated and it
interlocks in a beautiful way
this is not easy to do and it's
deceptive like how quickly you move
through this
but i'm telling you right now if you
want a challenge try and do a logo like
this where you have an element and it
repeats like two or three times and it
interlocks in a way that's kind of
really interesting not easy
so let's just start creating creating
the custom font
someone had asked um do you always like
to draw your own typefaces
yeah i don't know why but i just i just
love adding something that
is based a little bit on the symbol
itself
i think out of all the logs that i've
created there's only like
10 15 which have like a default font
next to it
the rest i just like it's just personal
preference i just like doing it
so it's not like will always let the
client pay extra for it i just i just
really like doing it so
sometimes i let clients be extra forward
but not always
awards are saying i'll call my mom thank
you we appreciate that yeah
doing everything you can to help us hit
600 i love that it's a family affair
guys
so you're even drawing the tm yeah
it's based on the a and the t is based
loosely on the e so just wanted to keep
it consistent
and in the end i um i noticed that the
optically the
the r the a the set e and r weren't
always
white so i ended up making the e and the
set
to see is it c in english or is that
i made them a z bit less wide so i made
them a bit more condensed
as you can see here
it's very minimal but i still think it
did the job
do you make your diagonals thicker in
the stroke than the
horizontal and the vertical i thought
about this because i watched the
previous episode
for some reason i've in this case i
didn't feel it was needed
and then in this case i will always
comment on it but we'll talk about it
later
so what the heck are you working on now
uh the colors
okay so you're done with the word mark
yeah
and as you can see i have two variations
of the r uh one of the r's has the
the line that's taken from the symbol
and one is has a slightly different art
but i ended up going with the one that
has the
r um which is the same angle as the
symbol
i just wanted to see if i wanted if i
just wanted to see it for like uh well
it's done
oops okay i can quickly open it
it's also in the slides anyway so so
this is the before and after
so just the final one on black on white
and this is what i mean with the angles
on the topography so the
angles here are the same as these angles
and this is the same angle as
this angle and every all the angles in
between
what about the cutting off of this z is
that the same angle that's the same as
the as well yeah
nice this one as well
so these are the calls that i used uh
slightly changed the colors that um that
razer used on their website
because i felt that green was a bit too
hard visible on a white background
this is actually the font they also use
on the their own website
i quite like the phones i'm using it uh
the latest stage for one of the expert
logos so these are just some of the
variations
uh so this is the that that their own
logo is
full green but i quite like it when the
symbol is green and the topography next
to it is either white or black
so this would be like the extra options
these are some of the razer brands they
have like um
said vengeance is a company which well
the investment company of the razer and
they have team razor so
a lot of esports teams are sponsored by
razer and they have this
team razor patches on their shirts
and i also did the logos based on
what i created for razer in the same
style for those companies
siddharth is saying this is just amazing
really inspiring and educational
thank you for saying that uh impulse is
saying
damn this guy's good thank you
i appreciate it i try to say that in the
voice in which he
is to communicate but i'm just doing a
little interpretation here so instead of
using mockups this time i've um actually
used
product photography from that website
and i
took some of the mice keyboard stuff
like that and put my new logo on it
to see how it would look so this is
before the team racer
mousemat and this is after so i just put
my new logo nice and this is one of the
mice
i i mean i really like that photography
it looks really sick yeah
so just with the new logo on it wait a
minute is that a glowing mouse pad
yeah some retouching so they have mice
or pads that are glowing
i think they have like that strip around
it oh okay that's what that is
yeah um
and this is what i think is for me it's
it's important with like a rebranding
that's
the identity is still intact but yes
it's just
refreshed a bit
so you can see the logo is changing
everywhere here's
topography as well change the did you
tweak the colors on these
uh products to match your color or or
you left it alone
no i left it alone i only swapped out
the logos okay but they're
they're branding and the official
identity already was quite close quite
close to what i created so i didn't have
to edit much
okay
so i just made some before and after
shots with my logo and with that logo
that was it okay awesome job dude
awesome
amazing okay so i have a lot of things
to talk about but first what i'm going
to do
is i'm going to switch over to my camera
here i'm going to say you guys here's
the original on the left
and the new revised logo on the right
so let us know in the comments right now
if you prefer the original
or the revised and i want to critique it
a little bit so
now i'm going to go back to me and i
want to can you pull up
wherever you were an illustrator file of
the finished
logo just on a clean background so i can
talk about a little bit
so a couple comments here philippe is
saying damn i want to go back to school
to learn graphic design
this is amazing ad for this
field so felipe cool right now you're in
school you're learning from us right
here
i didn't go to school so oh really well
i did
but i quit so what did you go to school
for
uh i did graphic design for two years
then i quit because i
already was freelancing a lot and i
would rather spend my time on that
i started freelance when i was 14 years
old so oh wow
dang it early that's probably not making
felipe feel that much better
okay let's zoom into i just want to see
the the just the two
uh the logo uh without the z ventures or
anything yeah just
i want to focus yeah so let's uh zoom in
as big as you can i put another
white one uh both black and white is
fine
if i can see it okay so i have some
thoughts on this
okay do me a favor when you have a
chance to zoom in as much as you can so
we can really look at
how this feels okay all right
so i'm looking at this and martin this
may be just my eye but
i i see some inconsistencies in the
the stroke width when i look at the a
the a feels a little skinny to me
and the the horizontal strokes of the z
feel a little thick relative to that
diagonal stroke and typically what
happens is vertical strokes are thicker
horizontal strokes are a little bit
thinner and diagonal strokes are
somewhere in between those two things i
think because
optically it looks narrower than it
really does so
i really like the execution i think it's
a really smart decision on your part to
stay with the brand equity in in the
razer mark the three snakes
and simplifying it to being a solid mark
you said to aid in
in your ability to redraw but mostly
it's like when you shrink this thing
down and if it had a stroke and had all
this complicated detail in the center
i think you would just lose all of that
yeah having a simple bold mark like this
allows you to reduce it down to a tiny
little
picon i think that's what it's called a
16 by 16 pixel thing
and scaling it all the way up i think
it's modern i think it's fresh
i would wear that in a cap i'd i'd be
you know because i'm a bit of a design
snob sometimes i don't buy products
because the logo is so bad
it's like the little finishing touch the
end of a sentence that sagi habibi would
say
and this is the right kind of thing it
leaves it open too
uh i i can see this being patterns yeah
there's so many things that you can do
with this
uh the thing i would uh ask you to do
in future iterations of this is just to
think about the weights and creating
the optical weight in in the letter
forms because i feel like they're a
little bit off like i really see the r
i thought about this so much before this
episode
because i watched the previous episode
and i was like damn he's right
and i've noticed a lot of my own work as
well like sometimes
for me it feels optically balanced
because i've been studying it for so
many hours you know
and then when someone else looks at a
bit of a fresh eye yeah
they notice these mistakes so i i agree
with you and that's probably one of the
first things i would change if i was
to you know work in this bit more yes
yes and the way that you can learn this
stuff if you're a self-taught person
open up a professionally designed
typeface type in the word
outline it and take measurements off of
it and if you don't trust that typeface
try another one and try another one
typefaces have been designed
by professionals and they've worked on
it for months sometimes years
they consider all these things and they
know because they this is all they do
they design typefaces and it's a it's an
art and a craft in and of itself so
that you'll see exactly what i'm talking
about okay so
i think maybe there's also me just being
a little bit stubborn
that's totally okay you're the guy doing
this and i don't want to be
a backseat driver a pixel offering art
director that's not who i am
you're right so i agree one of the
things that we wanted to do
moving forward with this logo redesign
series is to give each artist more time
to present their work and
present their process and that we can
have more meaningful dialogue about the
mark itself versus just rushing to the
next person
really like this and i think our our
audience our fans are liking the format
a lot better
seeing famous brands and seeing what you
would do with them with the real world
constraints versus just getting to do
whatever you want
i think it's been really helpful and
seeing your process of breaking down
the history telling us a little bit
about the mark about how
the founder accidentally cut himself
with a razor and when they went to file
it
they misspelled it but that was the best
thing they could have done
which is to have a misspelled word
because it's unique it's ownable
it's memorable and that's really cool
and
and for for people who are in the gaming
industry uh they're very passionate
about their logos and their products and
so i think you've done
you've done a really good job here and
we did break 600 for
for a heartbeat we were at 640 for a
second and then i'm not stressed
yes i think they feel the end of the
show is coming they're like we're out we
out
okay and the mom's locked back off yeah
mom's gone thanks mom thanks everybody
okay is there anything else that you and
i would need to talk about
well well um if there are any questions
about
sketching uh progress something like
that i mean i'm i have photoshop open i
can show
anything live if they want to like for
example if the questions are
how i draw or whatever i'm open for
whatever so
well nishant is saying by the way loving
the redesigned famous logo series really
insightful
let's see what other questions we have
uh do we live stream every single week
uh allan is asking this allah abraham
we do not live stream every week
basically everybody has a very
busy schedule so this is uh out of the
generosity of their
their heart that uh people like mart and
others who are on our show
they find a time in which they can do
this you can see he spent eight hours
just drawing
the the sketching part and then uh
comping and doing all this stuff it
takes a lot of time
so we're hoping that one day one day
really soon a big company
can come in and sponsor the show and
then we can we can share that money with
the the creators of this
work and hopefully you guys benefit and
everybody wins
so razer give us a call already right
or alienware somebody out there who
might benefit from this welcome give us
a call we're available apple i know i
know you're hard to get so
i'm not giving and i mention you okay is
there anything else here
mark do you see anything else in the
comments yes i found a good question
just
with regards to you creating a custom
font how do you select uh
you know the code the companion font
that goes along with you know some of
the copy on their website for example
well in this case it was already
selected because i like the form that
they were already using on the website
but in most cases it's just a battle of
trial and error
just trying trying out a lot of
different fonts and seeing what works
with it
i think one of the main rules when you
use secondary font next to your own
phone is
contrast so you don't want it to look
too much like what you've created
yourself
so i think that's important for example
if you create like a really condensed
custom font then maybe something a bit
more
wide for the secondary font
great go ahead smart
that's what i that's what i try to keep
in mind when i'm when i'm doing it
so for example if you use if you create
a server fund yourself
then maybe it's not the best choice to
also use the secondary service funds
i just want to read a funny comment from
john solis he's like what the hell was i
doing at 14
sad crying face that was good
i don't know what i was doing i know i
wasn't even thinking about my life in my
career
i was probably getting into trouble well
i wasn't that much
thinking about my career either i i
started fooling around in photoshop on
my father's computer and
things just turned into career because i
started uploading my work to deviantart
art and
such like that and all of a sudden when
i was 14 years old i got
contacted by a canadian company to
design an ad for them and i was like
what the [ __ ] going on and they
offered me like
400 for like an ad and i was 14 years
old so i could live with that for like
half a year
yeah that's what i was insane and then i
was like okay i
wasn't really sure what to choose anyway
in terms of studies and stuff like that
so i was like okay
maybe i should just pick something that
works with what i'm already doing
yeah yeah we went from there so yeah
well we're hoping that there's a whole
new generation of young creatives who
are watching our channel or channels
like ours and learning professional
design practices
i know that there are a lot of places
that you guys can tune in to see people
working on logos
and we hope that you find that ours with
the people that we invite on
are at the next level because we want to
promote good design practices best
practices if you will
and that's why i take a moment to talk
about some of the angles and some of the
things that you might feel in your heart
but not be able to articulate
okay zach norman saying
do you use a display style tablet i know
you mentioned wacom is it just a
standard wacom or is it one with the
screen built into it
okay so this is actually a bit
embarrassing
i got this one when i was 16 years old
and it still works so it's almost 12
years old
oh my goodness yeah your your tablet is
older than some of the people watching
your channel
and it's actually one of the first
things on the top of my list which i'm
going to replace so i'm planning on
getting a synthetic
like with the screen inside it oh really
this is like still
working perfectly and i haven't had to
replace anything but the pens itself
because i dropped the pants every now
and then
so i have to replace those but the the
tablet itself i mean
this almost like sounds like an ad for
wacom but that quality is really good
it's been working for 12 years almost
now and still doing quite well
so yes they're great products when they
work i'm just saying when they work
and they last a really long time i
happen to update quite often so
look i think it's about time for us to
wrap up the show here but i do want to
mention a couple things
uh first thank you for doing this mark i
think you did an excellent job
we'd love to hear from companies
companies big brands who want to get
behind what we're doing
alienware whoever is watching this and
you guys do me a big favor
everybody's watching if you've enjoyed
this drop a comment um
in this episode when it when the live
stream is uploaded
and just hashtag razer spell it
correctly
incorrectly r-a-z-e-r and hopefully
somewhere somebody smart from razer's
like you know
we might not want to change our logo but
we like these guys and we want to
support what we're doing
and that's it okay so who have we had on
the show today we've had mart
gomez i believe and he's at mart
berman's here on instagram and
everywhere else on social media
and he's from the netherlands you guys
if you want to check out his work if you
like what he's doing if you like his
process
i would strongly encourage you to reach
out to him
and hire him i hear him for a project we
all could use a little extra work right
now
and that's it so thank you mark and on
behalf of
mark and jonah myself guys we're gonna
get out of here jonah you know what to
do
and you know what to do don't forget to
like comment and subscribe hit that bell
notification already will ya
thanks for being part of our one billion
mission where we're trying to
teach you how to make a living doing
what you love and if you feel so
you feel so inclined be part of the
donation see you guys
next time be out of here goodbye